l'accueil des réfugiés syriens à
beaucoup retenu l attention au cours des
derniers jours autant sur la scène
fédérale que provinciale d'autres
nouvelles sont repassés passé et sur
le radar médias c'est qu'on en discute
avec mes collègues affectataire des
bureaux parlementaire de québec et
d'ottawa
marie-hélène thoraval et dans la
vieille capitale bonjour marie lalanne
bonjour manière des mahaleo essien
tavaillé 20h30 avec vont y arriver à
une annonce pour une garde-robe marche
qui est en cours
emplettes m'a passé inaperçu 7e oui et
c'était un mardi dernier
et c'est une vaste coalition qui
regroupe des jeunes de tous les secteurs
empare
des des gens du monde des affaires des
syndicats des groupes religieux des
groupes environnementaux de
développement des premières nations
des étudiants ce revenu annoncée en
grande pompe
une marche pour de 29 novembre prochain
dans mais elle cède 5 vela travers le
monde
et elle c'est une marche pour souligner
le début des travaux sur le climat
attali
et on veut faire une grande
démonstration pour que des pays fassent
leurs efforts
afin de réduire les gaz à effet de
serre donc cette game conférence de
presse pour annoncer cet événement et
pas assez complètement sous le radar
mais sachez
quel évènement apparat mais elle est
bien eu lieu le 29 novembre prochain
dans un peu près toutes les grandes
villes du pays
et dix membres dans le message
savennières réel de 100 employés
danone où effectivement ça va polluer
c'est bien évidemment
en raison des atteintes à bien sûr de
la semaine dernière
et pour cent la police a les
organisateurs que dans les circonstances
il était elle est possible de tenir sur
la durée un rassemblement
tout comme le 12 décembre au lendemain
de la réunion sur le climat où il
devait y en avoir une autre les deux
conducteurs être annulé la patrie
c'est compréhensible merci le maryland
à l'association des femmes autochtones
a beaucoup retenu l attention de
quelques semaines après ces élections
sont importantes dans la quête
y avait des cas à legé d'agression et
des buts de policiers de la sûreté du
québec un mode femme autochtone de
val-d'or
on en a parlé à l'assemblée nationale
cette semaine cette fois ça passe et
autant attention
effectivement c'est la commission
parlementaire des relations avec les
citoyens qui fait elle a été laissée
à la condition de vie
les femmes enfants et personnes
ce mandat d'amener lancé à l'été
dernier à presque deux ans maintenant
alors qu'il a pas à dire ça arrive à
point nommé avec notamment ces
révélations qui avaient été faites
par nos collègues dans le caca ça
quelques semaines
alors parmi les gens qui ont comparu en
commission parlementaire et à la crise
tant de regroupement
elle dit comité et elle bénéficiait
pas de taxe carbone
ebay n'étaient plus que fier et le nuj
istomin pour s'en expliquer at-elle son
point de vue sur la situation cette
femme diriger le regroupement % à
val-d'or
alors que l a salué cette initiative la
commission parlementaire et demi déjà
d'entrée de jeu
elle éviter que les recommandations qui
seront formulées ne suffiront pas
pourquoi parce qu'elles réclament haut
et fort une commission d'enquêté
publique pour faire la lumière
justement
sur les relations entre les autochtones
notamment le système de justice
et les relations presse pana avec les
policiers pour cela quoi les ministres
des affaires étrangères lequel il
n'est pas très chaud
on essaye le gouvernement trudeau va
tenir une commission d'enquêté
publique justement sur les femmes
autochtones jeff henckels et pense
qu'une deuxième commission n'est pas
nécessaire
on doit plutôt faire des actions
complémentaires alors à l'afp à rabat
à la commission va poursuivre ses
travaux cette semaine
après quoi les membres des députés
vont se déplacer dans les communautés
autochtones au cours de l hiver
y aura des recommandations et le ciment
évidemment le souhait de tous
c'est d'arriver à ce que l'association
des femmes autochtones 5 milliards
bien sûr moyen de ramener à québec
yves mariot à ottawa merci à vous deux
dans le somerset voix